-Welcome.
-Thank you so much, guys.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
And this is a very
short commute for you today,
because you were down the hall,
getting ready to
host "Saturday Night Live."
-I'm down the hall, yeah.
-Yeah. How is it feeling so far?
-It's mental.
Like, it moves so quickly.
It's amazing.
We started yesterday,
and I met everyone
and went into Lorne's office.
And all I talked about
was the goldfish
that he had in his tank, 'cause
I didn't know what else to do.
I was like,
"Oh, look at those --
Great view out your window."
-I wonder how many times
over the last 40-plus years,
he's had people, like,
panic and just start
talking about his fish.
-I honestly don't know
what I said.
But, yeah, it's great.
And it's also great
that you're here,
and there's always,
like, so much going on.
-There is a lot going on
in the building.
And it's a very special "SNL."
I want to know if
it's special for you,
because it's very Irish-themed.
You're the host,
and U2 is the musical guest.
-Yeah.
-Are you proud to be a part
of this Irish-themed "SNL" week?
-Yeah. Like,
it feels like the Irish are
taking over "SNL" for
the whole week, as we should.
-Yeah.
-It's about time.
-This has long been
feared in New York,
and now it's coming to pass.
-You knew it was gonna happen
one day, New York.
-There were --
Like, in the early 1900s,
that's when we thought
it was gonna happen,
and now here it is.
-There have been meetings
between Bono and meself.
-Yeah.
Do you feel a connection to U2?
Did you care a great deal about
them, being from Ireland?
-Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I love their music
and I know them a little bit,
and they're amazing.
And I think the great thing,
like, about Irish people,
even, like,
well-known Irish people,
is that we're all just very,
very familiar with each other.
So, like, the first time I met
them, it was like,
"Oh, Jesus. Hey, how's it going?
How's the family?
And, like, I've never
met these people before.
But, no, there's
a huge sense of, like,
national pride at them,
'cause they're our
biggest success story.
So to get to do
the show with them is great.
-That's really awesome.
Now, were you a fan of the show?
Do you have a favorite "SNL"
character, sketch
over the years?
-I love -- I mean, I loved all
of the sketches that you wrote.
-Oh, please. Don't.
-Every single one.
-This is some real Irish charm
happening right here.
-All your sketches are so smart.
-Thank you. Thank you.
You know, I thought,
because you seem really smart,
and I thought that maybe
mine would be your favorites.
-I get it.
Only smart people
get it, you know?
-There were nights
where definitely
only smart people got it,
and they were elsewhere.
-No, I love all of
Kristen Wiig's sketches.
-She's the best.
-So, she's the best.
So, Target Lady
and Sue and Penelope
and "just kidding."
And they're all so good.
And the cowbell, obviously.
Like, there's
so many great sketches.
The Californians is probably
one of my favorites.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
There you go.
So, you have a lot of favorites.
-I so many favorites.
-So, I want to ask --
So, in this film,
you play an
American high-school student.
And it's very much about
an American high school.
Even though it
takes place in Sacramento,
I feel like it will feel like
everybody's high school
who grew up in this country.
You, obviously,
did not grow up here.
How did you connect to the idea
of American high school?
Like, what did you know of it?
Did you know it
from pop culture?
-Yeah, like,
"Saved by the Bell."
-Yeah.
-That's how it is
in high school.
-I will say -- I got a real
"Saved by the Bell" vibe
off your acting in this film.
-Did you?
-Yeah.
-"Hey. Hey, how's it going?"
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-"Oh, no. Class."
Yeah, I think
everyone at home --
Everyone outside
of America pretty much,
definitely in
the Western World, obviously,
grows up with
American pop culture.
So, like, "Saved by the Bell"
and "Sabrina the Teenage Witch"
and "That's So Raven."
I thought -- Yeah, I know.
I thought I was
psychic for so long.
Genuinely, when I was a kid,
I used to do the look,
and I thought --
-Is that from the show
"That's So Raven"?
-That's from "That's So --"
Do you not know that?
-No, I kind of missed
"That's So Raven."
I mean, I'm familiar --
-Classic.
-Yeah, I think I'd
aged out of it.
I think, in my defense,
if I told people
it was a show I watched,
it would have been creepy.
-It would have been worrying.
-Yeah.